So, here's the next question I want to ask
you, simple true or false question. Does it make sense
to repeat an attribute along any given path in
the tree? So, if you we pick some attribute like
A, should we ever ask a question about A
again? Now, I mean something very specific about, by that.
I mean, down a particular path of the tree,
not just anywhere else in the tree. So, in particular,
I mean this. So, I ask a question about A, then
I ask a question about B, and then I ask a
question about A again. That's the question I'm asking. Not whether
A might appear more than once in the tree. So, for example,
you might have been the case where A shows up more
than once in the tree, but not along the same path.
So, in the second case over here, A shows up more
than once, but they really don't really have anything to do with
one another because once you've answered B, you will only ever
ask the question about A once. So, my question to you is,
does it make sense to repeat A more than once along
a particular path in the tree? Yes or no? Answer the question.